e
okay good morning everybody time to get
started sorry to be a little bit late
we're waiting for members to trickle in
from their various places and the
responsibilities that they have to
conduct this is the science technology
and committee uh energy committee for
May 14th and uh today we have an
executive
session followed by the end of session
committee lunch which some of us
consider to be the even more important
activity of the
day but we we'll begin as we usually do
by all rising and joining representative
Allegiance indivisible with liberty and
all so this is our final bill for the
2024 session of the house a Senate bill
Senate Bill 595
FN which is a bill that seeks to deal
with an
issue regarding poll attachment
rate cases and disagreements and
disputes and as many of you know the
original Bill actually
wanted to have the department of energy
create a formula that the commission
would then use and we're going to be
proposing an amendment this morning that
asks the doe to conduct an investigation
first so that all parties can
participate in coming up with a formula
that everyone can agree
with so that is
the uh strategy that we will use
so I'm going to wait a few more minutes
because there are some members who are
testifying in front of the senate or
otherwise occupied will open the exec
10:15 now does anybody have any they
would like to bring before the committee
wait so we have lunch reservations at
11:30
rep representative uh Vice chair Thomas
yes uh chairman thank you uh yes we have
reservations at Angelina's Italiano
Restaurant at 11:30 this morning right
now my headcount I believe is
18 um so we will take up the entire
restaurant that's about their
capacity and it's a not too bad of a
walk it's a short walk over there so I
encourage everyone to uh hustle over
there uh be there by they open at 11:30
so be there by by 11:30 and uh they're
going to have a I guess they're going to
have a long table for us so grab your
menu um okay and please be patient until
10:15 and we'll begin our executive
session representative McGee yeah I took
a look at the Senate bills that we have
um uh house bills passed by the Senate
actually that are pending and I'm
assuming that some of these might be
coming over to us for Con well they will
be coming to us for concurrence and I
was just wondering if we have had any
discussion or if you have had any
thoughts about the four bills um it's I
I mean I I pretty much know the status
but I think there may be some
conversation about what changes were
done in the Senate if we want to talk
about that um we have HB 458 which is um
this nuclear power study bill uh I and I
don't think they made any changes to
that and then there HB 609 which is the
fast track of the SEC which we changed
and I believe they changed as
well um but they made some I think minor
edits and then hb1 1431 integrated
distribution planning um that's in their
52 Senate journal and um I admit I have
to go take a look at at that at that
Amendment at their amended version um
I've heard about the changes but I
haven't read it
yet and then HB 1697 on the forest
uh so I didn't know if you had any
thoughts about those or yes I can
comment on all of those I have um
already instructed the clerk our
position on those bills on HB
458 we will nonc concur with the Senate
change and request a committee of
conference and the reason for that is
the Senate changed the wording of the
house version of the bill
to indicate that they wanted to see a
single
point of assessment activity for
Generation assets but the bill as passed
by the house allowed
for
multiple points of view to be
accommodated in the assessment formulas
that eventually get created so we
believe that that's a more proper
course to take for this bill so we're
going to try to ask the Senate to either
aced to the house position or maybe
suggest some modified language that
accommodates both of those
things House Bill 609 as you all will
recall is an extensive bill that reforms
the site evaluation committee the Senate
made four changes to that bill all of
which improve the bill and so I
concurred with the Senate's changes to
that bill the four changes and I'm doing
this from memory so I may get some of it
wrong but uh the four changes include
adding some language to the Preamble
about the importance of fishing game and
other natural resources some language
about adding
offshore to
the language in the Preamble Preamble
some language about that was suggested I
think
by well it doesn't matter who suggested
the language but anyway some language to
clarify how cities and towns get
notified
about
pending sighting
changes and the last
change had to do with notification also
so they were all good changes relatively
minor they don't change the substance of
the bill they just
clarify uh a few of the the
details House Bill
1431 was a bill that we passed to
reinstitute a long range planning
process for Distribution Systems and the
change that this that the Senate made
was they took
out some changes that were made to RSA
378 colon
37 which is the state energy policy
section of state law they took those out
uh restored it to its current state
basically or left it alone and then they
made one other small change to the
effective
date of the bill I believe so it takes
effect upon
passage once again I'm working for
memory so I'm not 100% sure that was the
only change but I think that's what it
was was and then for
1697 they made no sub substantive change
but they did change some language at the
very end of the bill to
clarify um just exactly
how communities would be not notified of
the process
of creating a carbon credits
registry once it's developed it it was
good a good language change so I
concurred with that as well so I'll
explain all of these changes in more
um yes I'm sorry we concurred with 1431
as well so of the four bills that
representative McGee mentioned we
concurred with three and requested a
committee of conference for one
uh did you you have something you want
anybody that's all that we've received
from the Senate so far I'm aware that
the Senate has passed some of our bills
out of committee but I don't think
they've gone to the senate floor yet so
we don't have them they haven't been
they haven't been adopted sufficiently
to come to the house yet all right so I
have a follow-up question sure since
this is our last actual meeting in
person in public how do we discuss those
further concurrences because I know we
have to kind of or I have to relay to my
caucus if we're not meeting physically
uh once we have a notice on a bill so
that if we have some you know if we
disagree or whatever we we have an
opportunity to do that well we can
discuss that as a committee my stry
would be to contact you and have a
discussion with
you um just the two of us and if we can
come to some kind of a consensus then
we'll move forward with that if we can't
we could call another meeting of the
full committee to discuss a path forward
okay
okay all right well it's it's beyond to
10:15 so I'm going to open an exec
session on Senate Bill 595
FN relative to the rates for poll
attachments and I'm going to move aop
pass on the bill and recognize
representative
amendment uh yes I I want to um move the
amendment 1931 H I recognize Vice chair
Thomas second moved and seconded that we
adopt the amendment 2024 d19
31h which everyone has received a copy
of just a few moments ago I apologize
for the fact that the amendment came in
amendment
was con conf refusing to OS and so the
amendment they supplied didn't achieve
the outcome we were looking
for so as a result of that we requested
the amendment that you see before you at
9:00 this
morning this is the original amendment
that we
intended for OS to draft and now that
the confusion has been cleared up we now
have the amendment that we wanted to
bring to the
committee so what does this amendment do
this amendment as you can read on lines
five and six request that the department
of energy set up an investigatory
proceeding about the use of a poll
attachment rate
formula that will be used once it's
developed by the Public Public Utilities
Commission to resolve
disputes when there are pole attachment
disp
disputes the rest of the bill is
language that sets up
the conditions under which the
investigation will take place and who
will pay for it
Etc and it's fairly straightforward
language not completely different from
what was in the original
bill so it does require that the
department investigate the use of a pole
attachment formula
and potentially to develop such a
formula and it also requires the
commission the Public Utilities
Commission to maintain and Report
property information to ensure that
information questions or comments from
the committee about this amendment
representative
Thomas thank you Mr chair um I'm looking
at lines 18 and 19 where um at the
conclusion of the investigation the
department shall issue a report of its
findings to the house Science Tech and
energy committee um with should there be
added well I'm not going to I'm not
going to hold up an amendment but um is
the purpose of this report to propose
legislative Solutions or they just going
want the purpose I believe is to keep us
informed Med as to
the formula that
they eventually settle upon as being a
relevant and acceptable formula for all
parties to to move forward
down now that that's a different
language I was looking at language at
2930 on page 1 and 1 and two on page two
but that applies to something
else essentially it basically
requires
that the department issue this report
and it's likely that the report will
contain the formula that everybody
agrees to but do we then have to
authorize that that formula or or okay
it or they can just go ahead and do use
line five and six that the rate formula
will be used by the commission when
resolving
disputes so once the report containing
the formula is available then that will
be available to the commission to use to
resolve
disputes yes as representative bernardy
just pointed out rules 16 and 17
indicate that the commission has to do
some rule making to it um incorporate
that
formula representative
Corman thank you um I'm going to couch
my question in terms of computer
programming um there are two types of if
statements if then and if then else I
see an if then I don't see an if then
else here so it says if the department
determines through this investigation
that the use of a formula would fully
compensate pole
owners what if the department does not
determine through its investigation that
the use of a formula what happens then
that's the else part that's
missing the implication I think is that
they have to keep going until they till
they satisfy the then there is no else
so then it's a repeat until Loop a
repeat until
exactly representative McGee thank you
Mr chair um so on line eight which
starts that sentence if the department
determines through this investigation
that the use of a formula would fully
compensate pole owners for their portion
of costs of owning maintaining and
operating polls arising from pole
attachments the stuff that's after that
semicolon is actually
um was added to the language in order to
satisfy my request in the hearings that
we identify some outcomes that this
investigation needs to solve for so that
it not determine uh among or against any
one attaching entity including the poll
owner be transparent to all parties
result in just and reasonable rates and
the development uh
shall oh the department shall develop
and finalize such formula meeting these
criteria no later than J January 1 2026
so we basically are sort of corralling
the process and saying by this time
frame you need to address these
specifics in your uh Ru making as to how
poll rates for dis discrepancies between
the parties will go forward um but I do
take your point that just the sentence
itself doesn't resolve in the way the
start of the sentence would would
warrant you know it seems like it might
smithing and I would remind them members
that Jael car will eventually have to
approve any rule that is developed by
the commission based on all this
representative Harrington yeah thank you
Mr chairman um little confused here I'm
trying to put my uh old pu hat back on
for a minute here and it sounds like
we're saying the department of energy is
going to come up with a formula and then
the Pu is forced to use that formula
into rule making well the Pu is a
separate entity that has the authority
to make their own rules within the scope
of the law so are we telling them that
they must do what the department of
energy tells them to do and what's the
point of rulemaking uh if that's the
deal are you asking a question or yeah I
am I I think we have an issue here and
I'd like to have some legal
interpretation of it can the department
of energy do they have the authority to
tell the Pu here's what you're going to
do in rule making because the rulemaking
just becomes a you know just a never no
never mind because we're telling you
what to do and I don't I'm not sure that
the department of energy has the
authority to do that and like I say I
I'm not a lawyer and I don't even
pretend to be one but maybe someone with
a little bit more legal background or
maybe from the Department of energy or
maybe from the Pu could uh advise us is
as to how that's going to
work would the department like to
you thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee for the record Chris Elms
Deputy Commissioner of the New Hampshire
Department of energy um I I would say
first off under you know if the
legislature passes a bill right we would
have that Authority but in this case um
you know we view this as the department
is going to pursue the investigation
develop the formula um that would come
out of that and put it before the Pu the
Pu would have the opportunity to
undertake their own rulemaking here to
incorporate that that formula within
their
authorities follow up yeah um okay
here's my problem it says the commission
shall conduct a formal rule maky to
incorporate the formula developed by the
department so what it's saying is that
the
must develop rules based on what the
department of energy is telling them to
do and I'm not sure that the department
of energy has that Authority or we go
one step further do we want them to have
that Authority because the Pu is an
independent body and they should be able
to make their own decisions telling them
to make rules when you get when you got
to give them the rules doesn't seem like
rule making and someone's going to bring
that up in the hearings in the rul
making saying well I don't like what the
department of energy did so so can they
change that if they given new
information or are they fixed in
according to this you must do what the
department of energy tells you and don't
make any independent decisions sure I
before you answer doesn't the language
on
line 15 that says within 30 days
following the close of the Department's
proceeding the commission shall conduct
a formal rulemaking isn't that a
legislative prescription that allows
this to
happen so yes yes uh thank you I I do
agree with you representative V that
that is the case um and I apologize our
general counsel is out today he was
comfortable with the bill but I'm not a
lawyer so I I if I get something wrong
or I'll ask Amanda to come running up
here to clarify something that I uh that
I said wrong um this is as much in part
because the department has the
capability and the capacity to go
undertake the investigation and the
proceeding uh related to that this is we
we view this bill as the legislature
saying we want you this process to
happen through the state executive
branch we will we will go through and do
that make that report with the results
of those investigation to this committee
um and then and then proceed with the ru
making that that you see here um the
result of any rule making whether it's
through the department or through the
commission does have to go through the
jail car process and I representative B
referenced this earlier that is another
opport opportunity for the legislature
to weigh in and approve uh the results
of that
rulem thank you representative muns
thank you Mr chair um I you know
the what I understand is we're replacing
a formula that's going to be developed
by the department with
um replacing that replacing the well in
in in St statute today there is there
already is a multi-part test the statute
says they must use a multi-art test so
we're going to replace that with a
formula so I'm not sure that
representative Harrington's concern is
is is valid I mean we already have that
right I mean we've already the
legislature has already said you have to
use this kind of approach we're just
changing that to a formula
approach okay
does anybody have anything else they
would like to ask of commissioner Els
Elms if not I'll let you go thank you
appreciate your help further discussion
representative Thomas thank you Mr chair
um I have two things that I'd like to
clarification on um from the original
Bill the date was on or before the
effective date of this section in this
in the amendment and you don't have to
pull it up but it's the first amendment
we got which was
um oh I don't even know where it is
anyway um the the amendment we had prior
to this one talked about a January 1st
date and then this one talks about a
July 1st date can you just walk me
through why there's three different
these probably because there were three
different
legislative um vehicles that were
created
and as each vehicle gets created you
probably have to change the date to
accommodate the
process that would be my guess I don't
know of any specific reason why it would
be why it would have been done for any
other reason okay the bill itself does
say that the final formula I have it
shall be developed no later than January
1st of
2026 so by by making the bill effective
July 1st of 2024 that basically gives 18
months for this investigatory proceeding
to all right finish its work um can I
have a followup yes follow up um my my
second question was on and I have it now
the um the prior Amendment which was
1668 I had a comment here that grants
cover construction and make ready is
that information included in this
amendment the new amendment is it a
concern that was covered or is it not a
concern read it again please grants
ready no that's that's just a note I
took on it oh a note you took yeah from
the
discussion so is that something that's a
concern and that might impact this
formula making or is it not go
representative McGee yeah I would say
that uh we we've got just in reasonable
cost recovery which I think you know in
the hearings with the Pu or in any
formula that's being devised they are
required to look at the actual costs
that people have to recover in order to
be made whole that's the kind of the
starting point in any of the formulas so
I think it's covered okay yeah all right
representative
bernardy yes I think the Make Ready part
is covered by uh compensate poll owners
for on P line nine compensate poll
owners for their portion of the cost of
owning maintaining and operating polls
so that's making ready for new lines and
whatever else has to be done okay all
right thank you representative Ms um I'm
I'm going to um I'm going to raise um
representative Thomas's two concerns and
concerns so um I guess that the so
you're saying this is a poker
game I'm I'm I'm I don't know if I want
to I don't know if I want to distinguish
it that way um so um I guess the first
the first question I had was on line
13 um we talk about the cost of the
proceeding may be assessed to parties
pursuant to RSA
36537 Roman numeral 2 I guess the
question I have there is I just want to
I want to make sure that that that does
not only include the owners of the polls
but the people that are bringing the
proceeding or the the the users of the
polls um I think the language um I think
the language in RSA
365 372 includes includes users but I
owners
okay I guess we could look up RSA 365
col colon 70 or col
says I don't know if there's anybody
here that can talk to
that well it looks like it's a fairly
lengthy
paragraph I mean I'm looking at it as
well and it says the um I see language
it says the Commission in the department
of energy May assess the cost of experts
accountants or other assistants hired by
the commission of the Department of
energy against the utilities and any
other parties to the
proceeding so it looks like that would
appear to to cover your concern
right I I I I think so I just want to
make sure that um you know
um you know what is the definition of a
party to the proceeding I mean if do you
do you have to formally ask to be part
of the process or is it anybody that's
that are all attachers going to be
included in the
assessment a representative I mean
commissioner Elms uh thank you back
again um and and again apologies if I
get something wrong I'm not the the
counselor or business office but in this
case yes so all parties to the
proceeding um you know could share in
the costs of the whatever costs are
associated with that proceeding uh being
a party means you know that's how you
participate and so uh you know in in
this case folks who are concerned and
who've raised this issue right are those
attaches who uh might not be a mandatory
party but they are the ones who would be
interested in expressing their their
their views here and having their voice
heard uh so we feel pretty confident
that those parties would be able to be
assessed follow up um so would would the
party would it an attacher for example
would they have to file some notice with
the Department or the puing saying yes
we are we are interested in this we are
an interested party or would would by
definition all attachers be included and
so I apologize for not being as up to
date on this but there is a process
which somebody becomes a a a formal
proceeding representative
Harrington oh go ahead I I had my other
two he's got other two my other two
concerns I'm willing to let me
so may I go ahead okay sorry what's up
um
um duly noted um one second concern was
and and this may just be a a drafting
issue or may not be but in line 15
there's a reference to required in
paragraph
4 and I believe that that's paragraph 4
of RSA 374
34- a i don't know if we need to maybe
include that RSA reference in
there this paragraph 4 is just kind of
hanging out there um so I'll leave that
to the um wisdom of the chair to decide
well there is no paragraph 4 in RSA 365
colon 37 expensive
investigation so I think it's reasonable
to conclude that paragraph 4 refers
a I think it's clear enough as as
written all right and then I will as I
said I'll thanks for for bringing that
that to our attention and questioning
that and then the last one okay is um
the
um we we we have these criteria that um
the formula need to um comply with um
fully compensate poll owners for a
portion of costs maintaining operating
you know etc etc um some of those are
fairly subjective who's going to be the
arbitrator of whether they have
accomplished the mission or
not how do we know that in fact um it
doesn't discriminate against one
attaching entity or that it's
transparent I mean is there do we need
to have some
arbitrator one would hope I wouldn't
suggest that the investigation will
figure that out and will provide that
information as part of its report would
that be a reasonable expectation
commissioner Elms uh yes under reading
this it would be the department that
makes a determination there and moves
forward with with the the um
investigation makes that recommendation
to uh the legislature puts this in front
of the Pu and then jail car would have
oh you have one more sorry so um I'm I'm
out a roll today and now I owe
Harrington double so um so ultimately if
if there was some concern about the the
formula it would be jail car that would
say no we don't think that that meets
the
criteria that that would certainly be
one opportunity and there might be
others through the puc ru making well
good now we know who's buying drinks at
lunch thanks okay represent Harington
okay I um I have a real problem with
this okay um what we're saying here is
conduct a formal rule making to
incorporate the formula developed by the
department so we're telling the Pu you
must do this whatever the department
comes up with and under 541 A3 for
making rules it says you have to hold a
public hearing receiving comments well
if you've already made if we told we're
telling the Pu you have to do ABC what's
the point of having a public hearing and
giving comments you comments going to
Comm in you can just throw them in the
trash I think this needs to be changed
to say conduct a formal rul making in
consideration of the formula developed
but the Pu has the authority to do this
by by themselves and they are not going
to be they should not be dictated by the
department of energy and it makes kind
of a fce under this rulemaking process
we're saying everyone talks about Jael
car I mean let's face it most of us have
dealt with gel car they are not experts
on um pole attachments or anything else
to do with poles or electricity or
telephones they they know the rules but
that's all and my point is here it says
holding a public hearing and receiving
comments if you're going to do that then
you have to give the Pu the flexibility
to make changes to whatever comes out of
that formula because right now it says
you you will incorporate it as is period
have a public hearing who cares if
anybody shows up throw all the comments
in the in the uh trash bucket I I can't
go along with
this well I appreciate your
interpretation but I would respectfully
disagree the ru making process which is
outlined pretty extensively in RSA
541a says that the department creates
rules which intended to accomplish the
legislative
intent of the legislation that spurred
the development of the rule
correct
and so the department or the Commission
in this case would develop the rules to
try to implement the legislative intent
of this
legislation and then you have to have a
public hearing so that the interested
parties can look at the rules you came
up with and say yes you did achieve the
legislative intent or intent or no you
didn't achieve the legislative attent
intent so I think this covers the
process
correctly now we could disagree I
suppose about whether this is
forcing the commission to
do the exact formula that the doe
investigation comes up with
or maybe the DOA investigation comes up
with with some flexibility in the for
formula that it suggests and lets the
commission uh have some leeway in the
development of the rules either way I
think the legislative intent of this
bill is to make it
happen representative McGee thank you um
so I just started doing a little
searching on the references to the rsas
in here um and I'm looking at the
general regulations under chapter 374
for pole attachments which is 374 colon
34- and what's interesting to me is it
seems like there's already been a stab
at uh at this what we're doing it's
already in this um in this RSA and so
I'm I'm concerned for whether we're
trying to reinvent a wheel here it it
says under this poll attachment sections
uh starting on section two which is when
there's a disagreement between the
parties it says whenever a poll owner is
unable to reach an agreement with a
party seeking poll attachments the
commission shall regulate and enforce
rates charges terms and conditions for
such poll attachments with regard to the
types of attachments regulated under 47
USC section 224 which is what you were
saying Chris is that there there already
is sort of a standard that they refer to
um to provide that such rates charges
terms and conditions are just and
reasonable so that's already in here the
authority uh shall include but not be
limited to the statutory regulatory
Authority referenced in 47 USC section
224 C and then section three goes on to
say the department of energy shall adopt
rules under RSA
541a to carry out the provisions of this
section including appropriate formula or
formula for appropriate uh apportioning
costs and shall adopt rules under RSA
541a implementing the provisions of One
Touch Make Ready the otmr as adopted by
the Federal Communications Commission in
47 CFR so and they give the reference
there so it it already says here what
the department versus the Pu should be
doing it I mean I don't want to read the
whole thing to you but
it goes on to say in exercising
Authority Under the subdivision the
department of energy shall consider the
interests of the subscribers and users
of the
services
um offered such uh via such attachments
as well as the interest of consumers of
any poll owner um providing such
attachments so it it already kind of
lays
out how it's supposed to work so I'm I'm
wondering whether this is and this piece
comes in as section nine starting on
five of the amendment line five of the
amendment so there are eight sections
here and this would just be tacked on
below that so all it accomplishes is to
say that the doe now has to create an
investigation in order to try and come
up with a process that I guess improves
on the existing process because there is
a process it's just that the Pu is in
charge of it if there's a disagreement
so does the legislation you're looking
at mentioned this multi-part test for
dis resolving
disputes the what test this multi-art
test well
multi-art uh let's
see because during testimony on this
bill we heard that what this bill is
about is coming up with a way to resolve
disputes when there when there is a
dispute between a pole attacher and the
pole owner and the current process which
involves a multi-part test has proven to
be
ineffective and needs to be
replaced Mr chair I believe that the
multi-part test is referenced in the um
the Pu um regulations in the rules but
right
okay so the problem this bill is trying
to solve solve is to try to come up with
a dispute
resolution process using a formula
instead of a multi-art
test so that would involve replacing if
the multi-art test is described
currently in pu rules replacing those pu
rules with new rules that
use a formula instead of a multi-part
test and that I believe is the intent of
this legislation didn't we now it's
legitimate to question whether it
accomplishes that intent but I think
that is the intent didn't we hear
testimony that there they were uh
deferring to the a federal
formula so there I mean there is
difference currently to an ex to an
existing formula for poll attachments no
without seeing the puc rules M I've got
the rule right in front of me do the
rules mention uh the formula as part of
the multipart test yeah one of the one
of the six um criteria is the formula
the formula adopted by the P the FCC and
47 CFR blah blah blah in effect on
October 1st
2022 so that's one of it looks like
that's one of the six elements of the
multipart
test so potentially the intent of this
legislation is to remove the other five
parts of the multi-part test would that
proposition would anybody like to
Weston we appreciate you being able to
answer our question this seems to be an
extremely confusing situation and we're
having a tough time as you can see
getting a total handle on it well we
appreciate the opportunity to be here
and help clarify and answer questions
and hopefully simplify this for you I
have with me Shan Caroll uh I'll let
Sean introduce
himself thank you for the record Sean
Carol with Comcast and here on behalf of
the New England connectivity and
Telecommunications
Association um so to answer the most
recent question um the intent as as I
see with this leg just is to essentially
remove those other five factors and
focus on an objective formula that has
been adjudicated up to the United States
Supreme Court um the the other five
factors insert um some uncertainty and
some confusion into the pole attachment
rates that are charged in New Hampshire
and so uh the legislation would remove
those and focus on a single formula as
the rest of uh the New England states
and most perhaps all of the states uh in
the country do um with a single formula
based on uh pole owner property records
inputs maintenance costs uh pole plant
costs um things of that
nature okay so that's the answer to the
question does is the intent of this
legislation to remove the other five
sure and I would follow up and and
remind you that the bill as passed by
the Senate mandated the adoption of a
formula uh in consideration or
difference to the absc formula and what
we heard from all of you is that you
would like additional process in the
form of an investigation for the
Department to look at
outcomes and then in fact based on their
analysis and the outcomes as prescribed
in this amendment as we read it they
would then determine whether the
adoption of a formula is appropriate and
make that determination and move forward
and I think we've heard questions today
about the sort of I'll call it the
division of labor between the department
of energy and the commission and I think
this goes back to the
restructuring of uh the department and
the commission uh over the past years
and so existing law actually outlined
some of that division of labor and what
you're looking at in the amendment today
I think builds off of what has already
been well
established excellent thank you okay I I
think that gives us some clarity as to
where we're going with this um
representative Corman do you have a
question for these folks or um no just a
comment just a comment uh to play
Devil's Advocate uh it's certainly
possible to come up with a single
formula that actually is a multi-part
Formula right you take part a of your
formula multiply that by zero or one
depending on what you want and then you
take Part B multiply that by zero and
add them all together I mean you can
have a single formula that's as many
parts as you want if you really want to
do that and and we would suggest and
Sean can can address this I believe
we've spoken to this before about some
of the elements or inputs rather to a
formula and it is not one size fits all
it is not rate setting it is in fact a
complicated process with many uh inputs
involved
so yeah I'll speak to the FCC formula
which is the the most widely used um in
the region and in the country but it it
is multi-art in that it has multiple
inputs so you have your pole owner costs
that go into it you have the space that
an attachment takes up on a pole and uh
as related to the usable space on the
pole you have the number of poles um
that the attacher is attached to so in
that sense it's multi-art in that there
are multiple inputs and those inputs are
specific to each poll owner own um so I
I don't know if that gets to your uh
gets to your point or
comment representative Corman I think
one of the reasons we want the doe to do
this is so that we don't have to figure
this out and all its permutations and
and
mathematical possibilities all right
well thank you folks for for speaking to
us and answering our questions is there
another one representative Harrington I
just had a a comment in general not not
to these uh people um hey thanks you
folks y it sounds like we're doing here
is we're saying okay go out and and come
up with a formula why don't we just
because we're the legislature why don't
we instead of kicking this to the Pu and
making them follow which I still don't
think is correct a rule that made by
somebody else and you have a public
hearing and comments cuz everyone's
going to say well someone could take it
to court I assume and say well we they
have to do what they were told to do so
what's the point of a public Hearing in
comment why don't we simply just say
that the doe will do a study in a report
and make a recommendation back to the
legislature and then we can decide if we
like it we'll say this is what you're
going to do and put it in the
statute well that's what the original
Bill did so you're advocating that we
just pass Senate Bill 595 as it came to
us from the Senate well I I don't
remember exactly what the word words are
in it but I think that saying that the
department of energy shall develop a
formula and then Force the Pu to do that
through through a rulemaking process
makes a joke out of the rulemaking
process so if that's the case have them
submit the their investigation back to
uh the legislature and then we can say
good idea bad idea and we can just put
it right in the statute if it's a good
idea and we don't have to screw around
making okay
I think the reason we came up with this
amendment and please committee members
correct me if I'm wrong about this is
that we were concerned that not all
parties were going to
get an opportunity to comment on
whatever formula was developed and so we
decided to turn this into an
investigation in the
hopes that that would allow all
parties to comment and to provide input
and to provide
addressed so we have two options here
one is we could pass the bill as it is
and just tell them what to do as the as
the original Senate Bill did or we can
pass this amendment and ask the doe to
allow all parties to participate in the
development of a formula I think those
are the choices here representative
Thomas thank you Mr chair I just want
some clarification on line uh 21 it says
that the um the authority necessary to
conduct this investigation and implement
this
subdivision why are we using subdivision
change yeah a subdivision of the go
ahead representative McGee sorry I was
just it it is hard sometimes because the
context of especially the Amendment
after Amendment where does it go what
does it relate to um the subdivision is
on pole attachment formula okay under
General regulations so that's this part
of the statute we're talking about thank
you representative Ms thank you Mr chair
I I think what representative Harrington
was suggesting and correct me if I'm
wrong is that there's a
third I rely on that um is is a is a is
a third alternative which I think what I
heard you say was we have the department
do this investigation they come up with
a formula then they come back to the
legislature we review it and then we
decide whether that's something in a
separate action probably next session we
decide if that's something we want to
implement
so so that so what I think what he was
suggesting was you know the
investigation but it doesn't become law
until after we've had a chance to review
it is that okay
well the amendment as written on lines
18 and 19 says at the conclusion of the
investigation the department the
department shall issue a report of its
findings to the house science technology
and energy
committee so that would give us the
opportunity to pass judgment on the
formula and if we didn't like it we
could submit
legislation at some subsequent point
that report probably won't be
forthcoming until
January 1st of 2026 but after that we
could submit legislation to fix it if if
we think it's badly
broken got a comment representative
Kennedy yeah looking at this I think I
mean uh representative Harrington could
answer this but if we eliminated the
sentence that starts on line 15 then I
think everything that people are talking
about the last 10 minutes would be
accomplished
well that may techically technically be
true true
but what would then happen to the
investigation would it sense I mean it
says at the conclusion the department
shall issue a report blah blah blah and
that's it that's it so then that would
require future legislation in order to
implement something correct if we like
it okay all right thanks for that
comment
representative McGee yeah I had just two
small thoughts um one is about let's see
to put my glasses on because I cannot
see um on the line uh on 19 where it
says submit the findings to house
science technology and energy committee
I thought we had discussed that it would
also go to Senate enr and I'm not sure I
know we discussed it but I'm not sure
whether that is appropriate or whether
we want to just send the report result
back to us so that it's not diffuse in
terms of a response but I would think
they might want to
respond
um let's
see we did discuss that
and because this is a house
amendment I decided that we wouldn't
include the Senate if they want to non-c
Concur and request a committee of
conference to add
themselves we can certainly
we would probably uh aced to that
request but I I don't foresee a
situation in which we would not share
our findings with them if they wanted to
see
them okay and then the other thought
that I had was around um SE the section
that starts on line 8 which talks about
what the Department is supposed to do in
terms of an investigation it doesn't
list anywhere that uh stakeholders
should should be included and to your
point that you made earlier one of the
concerns that we had in looking at how
pole attachment rates would be applied
uniformly across various types of pole
owners is that the smaller owners may
have differences that need to be taken
into consideration and I'm just
wondering whether this investigation
should be required to actually include
some of the stakeholders so that they
have a direct abil you can assume that
they're going to be included or you can
state that they need to be included and
right now I don't think the language
does
that I believe that if it's in their
best interest to be included they will
make sure that they are
included
representative yeah I was just going to
say I mean do we have to tell the
department to include people when they
do an investigation I hope
not do not I don't believe we
do representative
Kaplan yeah thank you um just in terms
of the the division of labor that we
that we're discussing and I think it's
clear in the amendment that the the
division of labor as we intended is that
the department draw rules and the Pu
department dropped the formula and pu
developed the rules and I don't think
that there's a problem with that because
after all the
legislature determines what our intent
is and and the Pu and the department
carry those out out so you know I don't
see I think we're we're getting down to
the weeds of of division of labor if we
have a clear intent both of those
organizations have to carry it
out thank you further discuss
representative
Harrington yeah I just listen to what we
just said um we saying that it's not
stated that the department has to have
uh input from other other groups but we
just assume they're going to do this
let's assume one group who thinks they
should be involved uh doesn't get
involved and or never is never asked
there's no public hearing there's no uh
posting it in the uh wherever one posts
things these days newspapers internet
whatever and then this rule comes out
because the rule has to do what the
investigation says there's no option
there they will incorporate the formula
period so there's no public input at
least for one entity
so next thing you know they go to the
Supreme Court of uh New Hampshire
because that's where the that's the
appellant court for the Pu decisions and
say we had no input to this decision uh
because when they had the rul making
they were already told by the
legislature you have no option you must
incorporate the formula period And I
dream would I like to change I would say
that we stated earlier simply report
have them do the investigation and
report back to the legislature with
saying here's our recommendations and
then the legislature can Implement that
by Statute we don't even need to go
comments just a comment on
representative McGee just a comment on
representative Harrington's comment um
on the other Comics yeah because there
already is although it's vague there
already is a process set up under the
poll attachment regulations for when
there is a a
disagreement um I don't have any problem
with us uh delaying and having a report
brought brought back to us because it's
not like there isn't anything in place
um and there were even disagreements
among the people who testified in the
hearing as to whether what we had was
adequate so it wouldn't bother me to
have it just be a report that comes back
and we take action after we actually get
to see what it is that we're
implementing so representative
Harrington
on
line 11 there is a
phrase one of the requirements of this
investigation there is a phrase that
says be transparent to all
parties does not that imply that
this investigation would
be so transparent that there'd be little
opportunity for a party to miss out on
participating well I think we're getting
a little technical here but transparent
means it's published so people can see
it it doesn't mean they necessarily have
any input whatsoever and I think that's
the part that's missing here because as
written we're going to have the
department come up with something
hopefully because I know the people over
there and I'm sure they'll do a good job
right Chris and uh but legally they're
not required to have any input from
anybody on this unless there's some rule
under the department of energy I'm not
aware of so they can come up with this
and somebody can claim oh yeah it was
transparent I read it on the Internet or
I read the report but I tried to submit
comments and no one would pay attention
to me so that's that's my issue here and
so I think rather than say we want the
uh Department of energy to basically
have the final say on this I think the
final say should be the
legislature because they can come up
with any formula they want based on this
kind of vague wording here and then the
Pu must incorporate that that wording so
I mean and I don't like the idea of
saying well if it's bad then we'll pass
another law to fix it I prefer not to if
when in doubt vote it out so if you if
it's a bad law don't say we're going to
fix it later on with a good law just
don't vote for it to begin
with so what would you Advocate that we
do with this bill just what I said just
get rid of that is as representative
Kennedy said get rid of that statement
about uh the ru making altogether just
say they they shall submit the report to
the science energy and Technology
committee representative
partial yes I tend to concur with
representative ferrington um thank you U
chair uh and I also like representative
Kennedy's Simplicity in that's striking
uh section four I think that makes a lot
of sense if uh we had uh the poll owners
be transparent and open to all parties
would that go any distance at all that
satisfying repr hearing concerns and
also I'm looking at 18 and 19 says
they're going to issue a report uh could
we specify what we would like to do with
their report pending further legislation
or pending put it in statute these are
further
discussion representative
rolds thank you Mr chairman and and I
apologize for my uh for my lateness this
morning I just had a a family situation
I had to take care of um I'm I'm
struggling to understand you
know why why we have as a committee have
become mired in
this debate at the at the level that we
are sort of debate ating the the
intricacies of what
is I to me normal procedure where
legislators pass legislation and
administrators Implement legislation
through proceedings that they are
empowered to to do and we have a pu we
have a
doe um and when I when I read the the
the amendment that we're here to debate
this morning I I honestly I come up with
it's sort of
another way of saying just
about the same thing that the bill as
amended came to us from the Senate
except that
we we changed uh the tasking to the
Department of
energy to conduct an investigation well
we said they they shall investigate the
use of a formula and then they we say if
they determined through this
investigation but down at the bottom of
that paragraph on line 15
we use the word proceeding or the the
amendment uses the word within 30 days
following the close of their
proceeding which sounds a little bit
more formal than an investigation I mean
in the original bill as given to us from
the
Senate the department was tasked with
um conducting a uh non adjudicative
proceeding the formula shall be
developed by the department in a
nonadjudicated proceeding within 18
months so that was the original bill so
I I guess I don't understand why we
Twisted it around here to to sort of
talk about an investigation but then we
call it a proceeding and then we're not
sure when they're
done uh you know should
says conduct a u formal rul making and
incorporate the the rule but give us a
report I mean I again I don't know why
we're so wrapped around the this seems
like normal proceeding I I'm inclined to
us okay so there is another option
here we've discussed the possibility of
passing this bill as it came to us from
the
Senate we've discussed the option of
passing this
amendment there is a third option and
that is we could determine that this
bill should be referred for interim
study if we're so confused by this whole
situation that we can't come up with a
solution then interim study is another
option I just throw that out there if
anybody has any thoughts on that idea
please let me know representative
partial yes thank you chair I would
strongly recommend not interm study this
has been kicked around for 25 years if
we have the opportunity to get some
forward progress on it let let's let the
department of energy get involved with
this and come up with some reasonable
suggestions after appropriate hearings
rather than pull it back into our
committee once again and kick it around
for another 25
years representative
Kennedy yeah just repeating myself a
little bit if if we get rid of the
sentence that starts on line 15 then
we're kicking the can down the road a
little bit hopefully not 25 years but we
will get some input if if people here
want to be so involved in all the
details you know go over every bit of
the formula um you know then we can have
them develop a formula and we can look
at it next time next term
whatever representative
Kaplan yeah I I uh concur with the
representative parshall I think we
should uh take the action that we're
here to take today um and I also feel
that uh by voting to Kick the Can down
the road as representative Kennedy
suggests would kind of M us down in the
same process that an interim study would
uh in terms of are we really equipped to
to be getting into the weeds of the rule
making and and determine you know is it
you know the different multi-art versus
formula and you know if if we're
charging the department of energy to
carry out this investigation I think we
can trust that they you know that they
are going to do it and I also like the
fact that this the way we've laid it out
in the language here it gives them an
outcome that we're aiming for in terms
of being fair and transparent to
everybody so you know I'm inclined to
vote for the amendment the way we have
representative
bne uh thank you chairman uh just kind
of looking through the original Bill uh
passed by the Senate um it includes a
lot of the things that we have in this
one and um it also uh shall give
difference to the FCC formula and which
we don't have in this one and I was just
wondering
um I guess I guess I I think the
original bill seems to cover a lot of
the things and I was wondering what were
the reasons that we put this amendment
in there was a lot of disagreement about
whether the original bill was the right
approach that was the reason we
considering we're considering this
amendment representative mons thank you
Mr chair I I would agree with uh
representative parall and and Kaplan and
and I think even representative Kennedy
that um I think we've done some good
work here we've made some progress in
terms of defining exactly what outcome
is that we're looking for and i' um I'd
hate to um have that all be for not if
we did interim
study
okay let me do a straw poll if you're in
please okay so interim studies
out if you're in favor of the original
bill as it came to us from the Senate
okay if you're in favor of the amendment
that we're discussing right here please
hand so a majority of the committee
appears to be in favor of the amendment
representative
partiall uh thank you chair I I would be
in favor of this if we could make the uh
at least the
change that represent Cy suggested um
and I would like that to be an option as
well yeah I think there are people rais
their hand with the Assumption we'd be
changing this I just want to make that
clear that you know I would be in favor
if it if we were to make that change of
striking uh clause
for okay let's see a show of hands of
people who would prefer to see the
amendment without lines the sentence at
okay so that appears to be an
amendment uh or in favor of an amendment
to the amendment so that being the case
I guess we're going to recess this
executive session and come back again
another day with a new Amendment lunch
again so
I think we'll do lunch today but we may
not do lunch on that day so
representative
Ms is there any chance we could
reconvene after
lunch there is a chance but I certainly
couldn't promise it it's a relative
either way we could recess and um but I
need to discuss this this amendment
change with some other folks before I
move forward with it so
um so we will recess
this executive
[Music]
session for today and we'll notice a new
executive session on another day it'll
probably be relatively soon because
we're going to start running up against
house deadlines soon I'll have to look
in the calendar to see exactly when they
are but uh representative uh Vice chair
Thomas has something to say yes I think
I was just reminded by uh Christie that
we only have till tomorrow to enact on
this bill because the deadline we need
to get it out
really the deadline is Thursday so it's
too late to notice a
right may I make a suggestion I vote for
the original
Amendment that's what I was gonna say
can we second representative cre could
we just pass the amendment in its
current form and then create a floor
uh we could try that it's that's a
um all right so we won't recess then
what we'll do is we'll cease this
executive session for now and reconvene
after
lunch by that time we will be able to
decide
whether making this amendment change is
acceptable and we can even ask OLS to to
prepare that
Amendment and then uh we can decide we
can exec the bill or finish executing
the bill then so we will now take an
official break from executive session
and Recon reconvene
at 1:30 we will reconvene at
1:30 to finish this executive session
much
e
okay ladies and gentlemen it's time to
resume the executive session for cipel
595 FN relative to the rates for poll
attachments and the first order of
business is I am going to withdraw my
earlier or ask representative McGee to
withdraw her early withdraw her earlier
motion to amend the bill with Amendment
1850 um I'm going to I'm going to
withdraw my motion to vote on the
amendment 1931 H 1931 H right sorry
that's okay got the number wrong okay so
that motion is withdrawn now we're open
to uh further amendments and I would
recognize representative McGee to make a
new motion I'd like to make a motion
that we accept Amendment 20241
195h recognize Vice chair Thomas second
moved and seconded that we adopt the
amendment
19508 so what this amendment does is on
line 16 and
17 after the word formula it adds the
phrase that gives consideration to the
and then on lines 19 and 20 it adds the
phrase and the Senate energy and natural
resources committee those are the only
two changes that the amendment makes
and representative Harrington deserves
the credit for suggesting the phrase on
lines 16 and
17 that gives consideration to the
report delivered by the
department because he thought it was
important to indic
that the commission is not being forced
to do something but they're just giving
consideration to the department
delivered report delivered by the
department so I'm interested in hearing
the committee's reaction to this new
Amendment representative Vice chair
Thomas uh based on what we discussed
earlier this morning and what we heard
just now I'm fully in favor of
it representative Thomas
yes not trying to be pedantic here but
um the previous um Amendment said that
it
uh it on line
17 um the formula developed was in the
previous one and now it's the report
any caution about that or anything no
the word formula is still there it says
the commission shall conduct a formal
room making to incorporate the formula
okay yeah yeah I see that now um and
before we had developed but now it's
delivered no no problem with that no
okay all
comments well seeing none I'll ask the
clerk to call the role on the question
of the adoption of the amendment 1
H Vice chair Thomas yes representative
ner yes representative Harrington yes
representative lii yes representative
Bry
yes representative Bernardi yes
representative PL yes some is not here
representative Kennedy yes
representative McGee yes representative
MC Williams
yes here representative parshall yes
representative Kaplan yes representative
muns yes representative Noel yes
representative Thomas yes Corman is not
here representative rolds
yes chairman o
170 okay by a vote of 17
to0 the amendment 2024 19 50h is adopted
for Senate Bill
595 FN I now recognize representative
McGee for a
motion a motion to accept well motion to
pass uh Senate Bill 595
otpa Vice chair Thomas second moved and
seconded that we determine that Senate
Bill 595 should be worthy of ought to
pass as amended
discussion seeing none I'll ask the
clerk to call the role on the question
of the adoption of the motion of ought
to pass as
amended Vice chair Thomas yes
representative ner yes representative
Harrington yes representative licky yes
representative brne yes representative
Bernardi yes representative PL yes
representative Kennedy yes
representative McGee yes representative
MC Williams yes representative parshall
yes representative Kaplan yes
representative muns yes representative
Noel's yes Noel excuse me repres
representative Thomas yes representative
rolds yes chairman Vose yes 1770 by a
vote of 17 to nothing the motion of
ought to pass as amended is
adopted without objection this will go
on the consent
calendar well the FN no longer applies I
don't
believe so I think we can put it on
consent I'll double check with the clerk
you can there's no if he says no then
obviously it won't
but and while I agree with
representative Thomas that the the
wording of that last phrase is a little
bit awkward uh it gets the job done so
let's move forward with it and uh
dispense with this bill and I want to
thank you all for being here and coming
back from lunch prepared to do this
business so that we can end our business
for this
bium except of course for going to
sessions and voting on the bills in
session and um dealing with any
committee of conferences that surface so
thanks everyone once again and uh enjoy
the rest of this beautiful day and the
rest of this beautiful month thank you